[Musik]
hallo meine lieben heute zeige ich euch
das rezept für meinen leckeren
apfelkuchen und zwar besteht ja neben
einem mit boden aus einer leckeren apfel
schicht und aus einem saale schwamm
topping dekoriert habe ich das ganze
dann noch mit gerösteten mandeln und
zimt und jetzt zeige ich euch schritt
für schritt die anleitung für die apfel
schicht benötigen wir säuerliche äpfel
nimmt er am besten granny smith oder
elster jedenfalls sollten sie so ehrlich
sein außerdem eine zitrone etwas
orangensaft zimt zucker stärke und
vanillezucker stattdessen könnt ihr aber
auch zwei packungen vanillepudding
pulver nehmen
zuallererst scheele ich meine äpfel mit
einem sparschäler
[Musik]
nachdem dann alle äpfel geschält wurden
schneide ich sie in solche scheiben die
sind etwa einen halben zentimeter dick
und dann geht es auch schon weiter mit
dem meister den benutze ich immer ganz
gerne bei apfelkuchen ihr könnt die
stückchen natürlich auch mit dem messer
schneiden
[Musik]
wenn ihr den schritt auch erledigt habt
solltet ihr auf jeden fall etwas
zitronensaft auf die äpfel geben damit
sie nicht braun werden
[Musik]
anschließend gibt ihr das am besten in
eine größere schüssel verrührt das noch
mal schön miteinander damit der
zitronensaft auch überall mit den äpfeln
in berührung kommt
[Musik]
nun geben wir die komplette speisestärke
mit einem teil des orangen satz in eine
schüssel und verrühren das klümpchen
frei an der stelle könnt ihr auch euer
puddingpulver benutzen
[Musik]
den restlichen orangensaft gebe ich
jetzt zusammen mit dem zucker dem
vanillezucker und den zimt in einen topf
und verrühren das ganze bis sich alles
verbunden hat wer übrigens nicht so der
zimt fan ist der kann das auch einfach
weglassen
[Musik]
anschließend kommen die apfelstückchen
mit dazu und das ganze wird einmal
komplett aufgekocht
[Musik]
sobald alles einmal auf gekocht wurde
gebe ich die mischung aus speisestärke
und orangensaft mich dazu führe dass
ganze kräftig und lasse das nochmal
aufkochen
nach dem aufkochen liegt die soße ein
wenig ein zusammen mit den äpfeln
verändert auch ein wenig seine farbe und
das geben wir jetzt in eine separate
schüssel damit das auskühlen kann am
besten gebt ihr das zum auskühlen für
eine stunde an die seite und in der
zwischenzeit machen wir weiter mit
unserem markt eick
[Musik]
hierfür benötigen wir mehr kalte butter
die habe ich ein stückchen geschnitten
und puderzucker zuallererst geben wir
mehl und puderzucker in eine schüssel
und verrühren das miteinander
[Musik]
wer kein puderzucker da hat der kann
auch kristallzucker nehmen dass es auch
kein problem dann schließen sich geben
wir das ei und die butter mit in die
schüssel jetzt kneten wir die zutaten zu
einem homogenen teig in der schüssel
finde ich das persönlich ein wenig
schwierig deswegen gebe ich mir das am
liebsten auf die arbeitsfläche und
kniete dann mit den händen weiter
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann einen schönen glatten
teig erhalten habt und keine reste mehr
an der arbeitsfläche kleben können wir
beginnen die springform vorzubereiten
und dafür nehme ich am liebsten butter
und mehl dafür streiche ich mit einem
pinsel etwas butter in meine springform
sowohl auf den boden als auch an die
ränder der springform gebe da ein wenig
mehr rein verteile das überall und das
überschüssige mail nämlich anschließend
wieder raus
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir ungefähr ein drittel
von meinem teig und kleidet damit den
boden der springform aus und weil der
teig soweit ist könnt ihr das ganz
einfach mit den händen verteilen
[Musik]
für den rand der springform rolle ich
mit den mürbeteig lieber rund und
arbeite mich dann nach und nach hoch so
ist es für mich persönlich am
einfachsten schaute einfach welche
technik euch am besten gefällt
[Musik]
wer möchte kann die ränder des mittags
mit einem messer begradigen das ist nur
für die optik das muss nicht sein
und nimmt auch bitte kein scharfes
messer damit ihr eure springform nicht
zerstört anschließend stich in den boden
des teigs noch mit der gabel ein paar
mal ein und gebe es dann in den
kühlschrank der teig muss 20 minuten
lang kühl gestellt werden damit er hart
wird auf den gut durch gekühlten
mürbeteig boden geben wir jetzt unsere
abhilfe lockt die abfüllung war bei mir
auch noch lauwarm selbst nach einer
stunde das ist gar kein problem
hauptsache sie es nicht so heiß wie
frisch aus dem topf
[Musik]
nachdem die füllung schön verteilt wurde
kann der kuchen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen
gebacken werden bei mir waren es
ungefähr 45 minuten da jeder ofen an das
packt schaut bitte weg aussieht darf
natürlich auch nicht zu dunkel werden
und so lassen wir ihnen jetzt
vollständig abkühlen für unser topping
benötigen wir kalte schlagsahne vanille
extrakt salat und schmand zuerst für die
schlagsahne zusammen mit dem vanille
extrakt einmal kurz aufgeschlagen und
während des aufschlages gebe ich schon
bei seiner fahrt mit hinzu und lass dir
das komplett steif schlagen
[Musik]
sobald die sahne steif geschlagen wurde
gebe ich den schmand mit hinzu und rühre
den noch ganz kurz mit unter wir reichen
auch schon ein paar sekunden der schwanz
soll nur ganz kurz mit der sahne
verrührt werden und dann ist das topping
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
für die deko verwende ich noch gehobelte
mandeln die ich hier in einer fettfreien
pfanne anrösten und ihr solltet das auf
jeden fall machen lasst diesen schritt
nicht aus denn die torte die schmeckt
einfach rundum lecker mit ihnen die
mandeln auch noch mit dazu gibt
[Musik]
ein vollständig ausgekühlten kuchen gebe
ich jetzt auf meine tortenplatte ihr
solltet wirklich darauf achten dass der
kuchen vollständig ausgekühlt ist denn
nur so könnt ihr den kuchen aus der form
befreien und er lässt sich schön
transportieren denn dem rücktritt auch
schon fest und bitte fühlt mal mit der
oberfläche eurer hand auf der torte ob
sie auch wirklich abgekühlt ist und
nicht noch lauwarm ist denn wir geben
jetzt unser seines man topping drauf
[Musik]
das topping habe ich dann mit meinem
löffel rücken schön ungleichmäßig auf
der torte verteilt und als ich dann
zufrieden war habe ich darüber noch ein
wenig zimt gegeben dass es natürlich
auch optional der kein zimt mag der
lässt ihn einfach weg
[Musik]
zum schluss kommen noch meine gerösteten
mandeln oben drauf und dann ist der
apfelkuchen auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und selbstverständlich schneiden wir den
kuchen auch noch gemeinsam an damit ihr
die einzelnen schichten auch erkennen
könnt ich kann euch jetzt schon mal
verraten das ist der leckerste
apfelkuchen den ich je gegessen habe
was mir besonders gut gefallen hat wann
die kombinationen dieser torte denn wir
haben zum einen diesen käfigen mürbeteig
dann haben wir diesen leckeren
apfelkompott innen mit zimt und vanille
verfeinert haben und obendrüber noch die
sahne schmandt creme mit den gerösteten
mandeln probiert's bitte unbedingt in
dieser kombination aus ich möchte so
gerne wissen was ihr dazu sagt wenn sie
ausgetestet habt hinterlassen wir gerne
einen kommentar abonniert main kanal
wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen möchte
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal wieder dabei sein
[Musik]